we're going to size something a little
bit different in computer file today
we're going to do a series of a few
videos linking together all about data
analysis big data are data mining this
kind of stuff so I guess the idea is
that maybe this is quite a broad topic
we can't cover it in detail in one video
and also some of the videos will link
together so maybe if we have a little
series on this we can start to really
learn about some of these in more detail
the idea being that by the time you've
watched all the videos you'll have a
really good idea of how to analyze data
and what you can do with data because
data isn't going away
there's a lot of it about I spent a lot
of time doing DIY and I'm always trying
to buy new tools because it just seems
like a good idea right so you know maybe
I buy a certain kind of saw and then you
know a few months later they're starting
to recommend me it's like a different
kind of solver so it's a slightly
different purpose that suddenly I
definitely need to be doing and I think
another yeah maybe I will buy that and
in the end I have 10 saws and I think
they had use any of this or